what are you doing here you're early i
haven't even done the intro yet go away
[Music]
good news it is almost a clock hello
everybody my name is markiplier and oh i
can't save now
that's what it was i never knew existed
oh that's wonderful
nothing can hide from you i know all
right so i don't know what this is about
it's saying that you know it's it's
almost done or whatever hello
door what the hell
what freddy
all right i'll see you on the other side
i guess
all right bye freddy
okay so i don't know what this is about
finding an exit and getting out of here
but i know of one exit which is from the
atrium area to
oh how did i even get there oh that
better be freddy
[Music]
okay
how did i get there in the first place
because i know i went
there you buddy
all right how much power you got 552. so
the minutes are now counting
roughly two minutes i think
which means that i need to
read and find my way through here i
guess
but
this doesn't make any sense like
is is this just like a last sprint for
collectibles so that i can get what i
need or what i've missed or something
like that so that i can
get everything before the end of the
game
this can't be the end it can't be i
refuse it to be the end you know what i
mean
i refuse it
no that leads to the dock area
there was another door here i know
that led to that atrium area if if i
went in here i only went in here to get
the party pass and then i went
somewhere else right
through the staff tunnels i think
didn't i hey freddy we're gonna go
through the tunnels
also i seem to be hi
i seem to be running out where did you
go thank you
yeah i seem to
i could have sworn
that there would have been something
else here because
is don't i still have the objective of
oh i don't
yes i do no i don't yes i do
thrill seeker and it's not like the time
has been
accurate to the minute until this very
point
oh i gotta hurry
okay
at least freddy's got some juice
maybe those new eyes are giving him a
new lease on life
and i think that the first time i went
through here yeah because the medical
emergency was like over here and medical
emergency i say i actually didn't have
anything wrong with me but for some
reason he detected that i had an injury
and i don't know what that's about
there's something over there
i don't know if this is worth it
is it worth it probably not
oh i'm running out of time
oh hurry hurry hurry come on come on
come on come on come on
foxy plush great get me in you i can't
see a goddamn thing
i have no idea where i'm going
i only hope i'm going vaguely in the
right direction which i think i am
whoa what
uh
no but i
this even before the ocular upgrade why
would you do that to me i have to put
the eyes back in again
what
let's begin by removing daddy's face
okay i'll be back okay actually now i'm
gonna save before i finish
that's a good idea then i don't have to
do that again oh my god
[Music]
how are your new eyes
i am having a hard time adjusting okay
eyes are amazing
wonderful colors and objects i never
knew existed
okay so i i i think that was the right
path because i'm pretty sure that will
directly get me right to the entrance
i think
i'm pretty sure come on
we gotta move quickly and i gotta find a
battery charger
i could have sworn there was one like in
in uh freddie's room
or the back of freddy's room yeah there
was
okay we're good we're good we're good
okay let's just not die
you know that's an option
freddy where are you
freddy
freddy hurry up freddie
no here
where are you going
freddie are you serious
freddie not there
oh my god
oh oh my god
are you kidding me
freddy
i'm gonna try the thing where if i jump
in the charging station
i might just automatically hop in with
him nope
they patched that
oh my god i'm gonna have to do it again
i'm gonna have to go through
this again unless i can go
oh my god no not tonight not tonight not
tonight don't do it
don't do it
oh my god where are you
okay this is wonderful freddy please
there you are you
i'm never gonna make it in time now
i'm never gonna make it in time
it's 5 56 i'm not gonna make it in time
no no no no no no no go away
go away
that is extremely inconvenient but go
away
[Music]
what is that supposed to be what is the
big
oh my god
no
no they don't you don't know that
ah yeah through the bathroom that's
right this is where chica was eating at
first okay good good good great great
good stuff good stuff good stuff
excellent stuff
the best stuff actually god this is not
the fast way is it
this is the slow way
right
i don't know
where am i
this is where monty was chasing me i'm
not making it lobby okay
what happened what what happened what
happened what happened what happened
what happened what happened what
what happened
what happened was moon man got me but
that doesn't really matter
what matters is that i died
and as you might have guessed
i'm going to continue dying several more
times before i get to the end which
isn't actually the end because my sense
of adventure was pointing me in the
right direction however
i was misguided and it led me down a
path of pain and despair
the bulk of which i will spare you from
but i will show you a little bit
because i know that you for some reason
enjoy my suffering i'm just here i oh
that goes down that hallway that is the
nightmare hallway
and that's not where i want to go
because that's going to be a dead end as
well and this thing don't go right back
up
because
it's not down anymore so this is only oh
it is there
i didn't know that i thought it went
back up after i
okay that's an option then okay that's
the option i'm going to go up there i'm
going to go to the main
lobby and take the elevator to the
atrium this is going to be the direct
path i know this i know this to be true
hello freddy this should mean that i go
straight up those escalators go right to
that elevator
and get the hell out of here and
apparently i missed that whatever that
is but i'm not gonna wait around to find
out because i
i don't care
correct hey little man do you know what
time it is the doors are open
why are you still here
you plan on moving in or you just want a
job
maybe join the internship program
you would make a great security guard
gregory
i think you deserve a reward
go check the main stage i was just at
the main stage i was literally just at
the main stage
also what the hell are you talking about
what is going on it's like
it's trying to give me like 10 different
things here hang on we're going back up
to the main stage because i i don't care
if i have to do this again
i always want to know what the hell's
going on
like i i know
something's up something's up i just got
to figure out what the up if something
is what something is up there
what is up this is the main stage
okay vanessa i'm at the main stage
are you you serious
are you
vanessa are you serious right now
vanessa
vanessa told me to stay on this stage
and there's no way that i'm gonna make
it to the exit so i'm just gonna stay on
the stage and that's it oh god oh god no
no no oh oh okay all right okay
so you sprint a bit but you're not that
long so
[Music]
what what happened i saw a mission pop
up that said plan a
what
[Music]
preparing
procedure
what i'm gonna do this time
is i'm just gonna go pop in a charging
station because i think that's how you
get away from the moon man all right so
i'm i know there's a charger right here
what happens if i do this
it says get to recharging station i am
at recharging stations and objects i
never knew exist are you serious nothing
can hide from me now are you serious
hey stay
you serious you serious right now you
serious you serious are you serious are
you serious are you serious are you
serious you serious are you serious he's
serious
are you serious he's serious right now
he's serious you being serious you
serious right now i'm pretty sure moon
man got me because it hits 6 a.m and i
can't stay up past my bedtime
so i'm pretty sure that's why that
happened but
no that doesn't work
right
okay let me just
i don't know let me i don't know i don't
know guys i don't know just let me hang
on hold on hold your
horses nope
i get found no matter what i do okay
great good great of course it is okay so
i'm gonna gun it straight to the
entrance i know the quickest path and
i'm just gonna go for it you ready to go
for an adventure with your jiggly head
are you ready go check the main stage i
did that and there was nothing you lied
to me
you tried to trick me
there was nothing at the main stage and
you know it
you know there was nothing i could see
that there's nothing i've got
supervision
never gonna trick me again
you can't
all right hey look at that the doors are
open well wonder what's gonna happen
when i walk right through them
let's go freddy
goodbye everybody i guess oh
freddy it's open let's go
no
i cannot exit this facility
of course you can come on we can hide
you somewhere
without a recharge station
my systems would shut down within an
hour
it is a safety precaution
it is
my design
this is where i must stay
do not return
it will never be safe
i will miss you freddie
if i leave now
nothing will change will it
there will be more disappearances
yes
i am afraid that is correct
gregory you have a choice to make
the door is open fanny you can go
or you can continue to investigate the
secrets of the pizza plex i feel there
is something else going on besides fanny
oh interesting
do i wish to stay stay leave vanni what
kind of do you want to stay fanny
gregory what what are you saying
fanny
uh yes vanie is the name of the rabbit
okay save stations will no longer be
available if you stay if gregory is
caught it is game over so if i want to
do this again i just have to start from
the same place i did what is this staley
vanni vanny what is this what does this
choice mean i'm clicking it
we saw her hideout right
and phaserblast
maybe we could catch her there
if she thinks i escape maybe we can
surprise her yes come
let us end this
okay
oh oh what what
what
what what
oh what what
what
happened
what what
what
what's this happened
is it because freddy didn't have all the
upgrades whoa my god
holy crap i'm guessing that's the thing
oh my god please don't
i know you're there do you oh god
um so
yeah i'm guessing it's because freddy
didn't have all the upgrades that he
couldn't fight properly or something
like that
i there no no no it's game over if i
don't
do something
i can't see anything
can you hear me
[Music]
okay
are you coming up after me i can't tell
where am i why am i here
oh this goes back down that's right okay
oh
hello
what
what is happening
[Music]
what
you
are my
super star
[Music]
did they run out of budget for the last
animation
in no way is that actually the ending
the real ending that's not it okay so
that's what i've been saying all along
vani
is just red herring right
a hair
like a rabbit a hair h-a-r-e
red eyes are
literally a red hair ring
i think there's something else that's
going on in the
pizzeria right there's something else
that's happening
uh you're getting me you understanding
me and i bet
the other option being to
stay in the place is whatever i'd go
hurry
the other option being to stay
disassembling monty
getting the last upgrade
figuring out what's really going on here
you have yourself the right thing
to get the true ending
it's
so clear
i think hold on we're not doing any
conclusionary stuff yet because stop
i knew
that the stay option was
the right choice i just wanted to do the
vanity thing because it's like such a
strange thing
plans to reopen next season oh good
there is something else going on here
and i'm gonna get to the bottom of it it
is a little unfortunate that where where
does this even say
oh man look at those
there's a 6am autosave slot
no there's not
wait what is this
oh is this the choice
please tell me that's the choice please
tell me that gets me right to the choice
i would love that it probably doesn't
what's that gregory you have a choice
looking at this the door is open
party passes give party passes to staff
bots to unlock areas of the pizza blacks
okay staying i am glad
here i found this party pass there are
areas we have not investigated no
way superstar thanks door
thanks talking rolling shutter door
no i knew it i probably still can't save
i'm betting
but that's the thing right so the party
pass so let me get into the
uh
whatchamahoozit right
the
the golf
thing
the golf you know the golf right the
golf
okay
so what i need to do
is i need to be very careful
and pretty much i'm just going to be
riding inside of freddy for the rest of
forever and i'm going to make sure i get
to charging stations or else he's going
to kill me
but now that i've got
roxy vision i can see everything that
needs to be collected it is so bright
and vibrant in here
it's lovely
this is lovely
but this means that there are going to
be things
that i can find i can go and get all the
collectibles and then there is probably
a true ending somewhere around here it
is awfully inconvenient that i can't
save
but i'm i i know
i know there's a way i know
and then i'm gonna get freddy these claw
upgrades
the club grades
there's something up there that i missed
how did i miss all this stuff
did i die in a
save at some point and not
come back
oh god power power where's power
power where's power
this
is sucking power like no one no
one would believe
can i get out can i get up oh are you
kidding me oh
oh
don't do that to me
[Music]
okay
so
at least for now
whoa hey bud
come here you
over here bud
yeah just boom right over
all right so i just need to figure out
if there's anything else on this level
and then i'm gonna hop out
because i'm not about low power yep not
staying in there
i think there's one in the daycare area
but let me go grab this thing first
because i know that there's something
going on i always thought it was too
obvious it was it was just too obvious
like hi
it was just too obvious there was no way
that it all boiled down to just that
right
chica name shirt
hi uh
so there is something else going on
and i gotta get to it um
i know there's a charging station over
here and there's probably collectibles
in the daycare that i did not get before
you guys really uh
anyway that's the secret that those
things i always wear
perfect easy peasy so what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna make my way over to golf
but i'm gonna methodically get all this
stuff first because apparently there was
a lot of collectibles that i did not get
oh good actually i might as well comb
through
the daycare
and figure out what's going on there you
know i'll be back
i'm gonna be back
uh
when i figure out exactly what it is
that i need to do but for the first part
i'm just gonna go and try to get all of
this stuff here so that i can
knock this off my bucket list fast bear
theater i never even went over here
fazbear theater
oh
freddy
you in the fazbear theory yes you are
how many things in this game did they
make that's the uh freddie over here
buddy thanks hell that's the thing
there's so many areas in this game and
it doesn't feel like they're all
utilized what i think happened how did i
miss one goddammit what i think happened
is
they
obviously put an incredible amount of
detail into the game itself right the
actual environment of the game and then
i think
now hear me out on this one hear me out
on this one i think that the game
originally played a lot differently than
the way it does right now because
what we have
is a series of really interesting
moments
that are connected in a way that doesn't
necessarily make a lot of sense
or isn't as cohesive as one would think
it would be um and i think what's
happening like this area back here
there's a flashlight charger here i i
mean i'm all for like exploration what
is with
oh
gross um okay
sanitation isn't a high priority around
here can i get that
[Music]
okay
yeah
and then
like in the process maybe that there was
an issue and development or maybe like
something went wrong or maybe i'm
completely wrong and i'm just like
slinging out baseless accusations but
there there are a lot of really polished
moments like and really fun interesting
moments that feel very uh nice and
they're they're cohesive and they're the
experience is good
and and on the other side there are
moments that do not feel as connected
and other things
the the spirit
what the hell enjoy the comedy
what
okay
can i enjoy the comedy stylings of
snapbot
are you
okay
you
you gonna do anything
like this why would they make a little
theater here i mean great for
getting stuff like that hey what are you
doing
you okay buddy stage fright you're
nervous
because this is another thing that feels
like it was going to be something but
maybe it's not going to be something i
don't know
the bb world game has been acting up
customers have complained that it starts
to glitch over time i head to the
theater to fix it and now it's gone i
never saw a move request so it should
still be here somewhere i guess i'll
check after the company meeting
i remember the company meeting thursday
at like 11 30 or something like that
fascinating
oh god was i not supposed to come down
here
uh please tell me there's a way that i
can get out please okay good good good
ah
a place for babies
[Music]
okay
interesting
okay cool
where am i going what am i doing
hey bud
don't you get me
it's game over oh god
how
you
oh my god no not monty not monty not
monty not monty i can't stop monty i
can't stop monty freddy freddy please
freddy freddy now now freddie now now
freddy
fred i need you right now
please be
oh god oh god that's not freddy freddy
freddy
no oh no no no
freddie please oh my god no not like
this not like this please
give me in give me a friend
[Applause]
freddy don't wait your turn god damn it
freddy
oh my god no no no not like this not
like this freddy
oh my god oh my god are you serious are
you serious right now you cannot be
serious
freddy freddy
oh my god freddy
ready you bastard
[Music]
all right guys that'll do it
for this
episode i found this party this morning
there was a patch for this game
and i think
i think what the intention was to fix
some bugs and possible exploits with
freddy being able to open doors or being
summoned too closely clearly the way
that he's summoned now has changed
i think what they did
was
make
freddy come to you from farther away and
not teleport so much
but in doing so it seems like they broke
him entirely so thank you everybody so
much for watching i'm done
there are links in the description that
i know you haven't clicked on ones to
distractible and
tears2cloakbrand.com so click on them or
i will come find you
i will find you
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you